[Music]
[Applause]
luno the fastest easiest way to buy
bitcoin
if you're just getting into crypto it's
the perfect place to start
hey hey and welcome back to my channel
it is of course supposed to buy
blockbuster
dollars there's links everywhere it's
powered by
plus capital the
hey what's going on can you hear me okay
yeah yeah can you hear me
yeah perfect perfect yeah we were um
you caught me listening to the
congressional hearing and um
live on clubhouse with a group of uh
of people who are interested in
regulatory uh kind of stuff
and so we're just doing a little
feedback on that but
uh you pinged me and said you needed uh
someone to fill in so here i am
uh i'm gonna pass on lunch pass on
regulatory feedback
no i love that well firstly i appreciate
your time i've called you gigger chad i
don't know if you've noticed but um i've
called you gig a chad because like
what kind of gig what kind of person has
to be only a giga child that can
literally just come online
like that no i love it i really
appreciate it thank you so much
um but what is going on with this
congressional hearing
i had no idea um obviously i'm in the uk
i didn't know this was happening so give
me the lowdown
yeah it was a big deal like a lot of us
had been
um kind of feeling a bit of doom and
gloom about it because we had the big
china move to ban mining i
kind of miscalculated the scope of it i
thought it may have been just like a
shuffling of the deck and
and kind of weeding out some bad actors
but it appears that it's far-reaching
um that affected the market a little bit
uh negatively and then we knew that this
hearing that
maxine waters was putting up here
uh today um the title of which was like
america is on fire is cryptocurrency
gonna burn down the world like
really negative um i expected a lot of
esg
energy flood tether flood
um and then tax confusion and regulatory
confusion the recurrent word of
cryptocurrency
versus bitcoin uh an attack on
proof-of-work mining
you know all of those topics came up but
i think it was a net win
um for bitcoin in particular i thought
the
the um the people who were testifying as
witnesses did a fair job and i think
some of the uh uh the congress
men and congress women said ridiculously
foolish things comparing
investments in cryptocurrency to playing
the california
lottery for example and recommending
that as an
alternative it's like ridiculous that
dogecoin is a threat to the us dollars
is laughable uh that ethereum is a
threat to bitcoin
it's ludicrous so uh look my blood
sugar's a little low
but my energy is always there if i
collapse
just send call now it's fine no it's
fine i got you
i got you it's cool but yeah it's really
odd because i heard
um the other day somebody who i don't
know who it was
i'm not gonna oh maybe it was elizabeth
warren i don't know i'm not american but
i think it was elizabeth warren that was
sort of
that was of using bitcoin and doge in
the same sentence
saying how they're a threat and they're
bad for the environment
and that um you know it's gambling and
it's dangerous and it's unregulated
and i was just not thinking how can you
even put doge and bitcoin in the same
sentence like i know i for one love to
sort of like joke about doge like i
still i still think doge is hilarious
and i love it from that standpoint it's
dumb yeah so for those listening on
audio
um jason has just written um it's done
on a piece of paper but it is but i
don't understand
what what what was the point in this
congressional hearing why did it start i
i need background
well i mean these hearings are to
explore
uh regulatory positions um and to
introduce the discussion
uh to the american people and to other
congress people who will be voting on
topics you know there's an agenda behind
all of this
believe me all of these folks are bought
and paid for
by industries so you're talking about
that's awesome
yeah it's awful so you're talking about
some of the most
regulated and entrenched institutions
that have built america oil
power energy uh the finance
system and here you know bitcoin kind of
uh
it it has so many um
[Music]
relevant i wouldn't even say
implications
it it crosses so many boundaries and i
think it catches people off guard
if you approach bitcoin superficially um
you may you may not uh respect it but if
you spend any time with
it and uh like i challenge your your
listeners to listen to
gigi's book 21 lessons it's like the
only bitcoin book
that i can finish at like 1.2 or 1.4 x
speed in like two hours and i listen to
it
all the time when i drive uh to my
second home i really enjoy it
uh the 21 lessons by gigi it's fantastic
and it really
it just lights my brain on fire in
regards to
um you know how important bitcoin is
well what about it
it's good because i'm finishing up a
book right now and i'm a bit terrified
to let the world see it so go on
oh please i wouldn't even do it justice
i mean it takes you through all of the
relevant topics of like
the monetary system why bitcoins bitcoin
what
mining is it gets into some technical
stuff because gigi is an engineer
not an economist uh he says he's
non-technical but the book is
uh sort of technical but it it talks
about
things in such a way that's so inspiring
to
someone like me who who tries to uh be a
bit cognitively diverse in my own
kind of approach to things i'm not a
technical in terms of
coding but i i
i do like science and math
and i enjoy
pressure testing some of the things that
are going on like proof of work mining
it really bothers me when i hear people
talk about
bitcoin mining as some type of like
uh program that's random randomizing
numbers and competing
for a reward and that's what it is so
it's a giant
waste of computational energy this huge
power hog that does absolutely nothing
right
that's not what it does like i wish
people would step
back and i'm i'm asking technical people
to challenge this
bitcoin proof of work mining is an
elegant timestamp
server because that's really what
satoshi created
it's keeping things in order
transactions in order and then it places
it in the block
and then and then broadcast that in a
decentralized way where everyone has
the proof of time time
that's what bitcoin mining does it
maintains
the timing of this giant timestamp
server
and why wouldn't that take energy give
me a break yeah
wait no absolutely give me a break
okay so he's showing dumb again no
you're 100 right and
you know i've been i've been writing so
much about this recently and i'm writing
about the difficulty adjustment
and i think you know everybody you know
buys bits people buy bitcoin but not
everybody who buys understands the
intricacies or the elegance of the
technology
and um you know everything you know you
brought up china and everything that's
gone on there
it doesn't matter of course like we were
saying you know it's bigger than we
thought and i think i saw
um i think it's zach rowell um
his last name correctly he was saying
that um you know you can't just plug an
asic
into a volcano you can't just plug in
like the infrastructure to mine takes
time and so
you know obviously this will have an
effect on the network
but the network will survive because of
these these
delicate intricacies things like the
difficulty adjustment will just kick in
um and i i'm absolutely with you and i
think that i'm actually happy that the
fight has come up
i like it because i personally have
learned so much about it
more people are learning about it it
wouldn't have given everybody a reason
particularly nick carter he did a great
job
um of explaining this topic you know
it just wouldn't if we continued going
the way we were going it really wouldn't
um
and i've won i've learned so much
especially about the fact like you said
everything
uses energy but it's about whether it's
worth it
you know in terms of all the benefits of
bitcoin i mean obviously it's worth it
i i i tend to find it offensive for
someone to
have energy i mean look stop using a
blow dryer
right not really christmas lights
yeah and again it's so dumb like this is
a really like that's the the theme of
the day like these discussions
they're dumb they're it's just so dumb
to talk about
like who should use power for what and
like
i even tweeted today climate crisis
laugh out loud like i'm i wait wait
yeah just have a question okay so like
this is obviously such a big thing
um i mean do you think they're like like
bitcoin aside do you think that the
climate crisis do you think we're
there's doom coming and the world is
ending and we're all about to go
underwater are you like a greta
thundberg
lover or no there's no climate no i'm i
just sit here and i listen to people
like oh it's so hot
because of carbon and like
and people we're destroying the planet
like i'm not sure about that
like i'm just not sure about that i i
don't know if there's a
climate crisis or do you do you support
that that
that bitcoin mining is destroying the
planet
no certainly not um but you know like in
terms of the wider conversation what i
think is really interesting
and somebody hurts all cans or
destroying the others
no i'm asking you do you feel no of
course not okay
you think that the combustion engine and
our cars
are are destroying the earth like
it's going to cause the end of
civilization like do you feel like
that's
that's going to happen i mean not really
no
not particularly but what i want to say
though about this topic which is
interesting because somebody actually
pointed this out to me
they said that um so when we were
younger i don't know what it was like in
the states but when i was younger
in england um in school we were the
narrative we were taught is global
warming okay
global warming oh yeah yeah oh nice you
got your uk possible but you didn't grow
up
you didn't grow up here you grew up over
there you always try and say that you're
english but you're just not and trust me
you support man you if you were
mancunian you'd be a whole different
vibe if you were actually mancunian you
were
american through anyway back to what i
was saying
so um my job is to distract you
so yeah i know you're doing a good job
of it i've done a good job of it
no so when we were younger in the uk
where you were not
um we were always taught about global
warming but now
the catchphrase and the slogan has
changed now it's the climate emergency
i mean for me the fact that you have
like marketing campaigns behind things
um is always very concerning i mean i'm
not gonna get into um
you know the good old pandemic i can't
be bothered but i'll just say
you know if things are that deadly you
shouldn't need a marketing campaign
behind it
yeah i i have unfortunately and i don't
know when
the us um it was recent
the last 10 15 years the united states
made it legal
for them to launch psychological
operations against its citizens we've
used psyops which was like a special
forces military thing
uh you know around the world during
times of war but it was made legal
uh to use against u.s citizens and and i
now have
challenged a lot of my own beliefs you
know um
when it comes to these big headlines
climate change ufos
um well all this wait i believe in ufos
i believe yeah but i'm just saying like
now
like all bets are off because the
government's using
psychological operations against its
citizens i i
i don't know what's going on i'm
questioning everything now
and trying to kind of primary source
verify it like
uh if any ufo uh or any aliens are
listening
stop by pick me up let's do this
i want to know if you're real i'm real
let's rock
jason do you have do you have um a
favorite conspiracy theory
because i heard one which i'll share
with you after which was honestly so
cool
i i don't i i'm not a huge conspiracy
theorist um you know i've read beyond a
pale horse
and uh you know i love the uh
bilderberg group guys you know it's
always fun to think there's like a group
of people in a very
sultry environment with big leather
chairs and
and drinking like cocktails that you
know like
like the elite like the yeah yeah
illuminati
you're going uh you know raise the price
of oil
yeah yeah and they and that's the comics
double masks yeah let's wear two masks
uh
you've had your vaccine not good enough
there's delta
delta we need to wear your masks
no i'm with you i'm so with you no i
like
that i i don't know i don't know like i
was just
like right yeah yeah right yeah what
what's your favorite conspiracy theory
no wait so i
there's definitely a table with a group
of probably men where they sit at maybe
like one woman or something
and they say this will be the agenda no
women really
no they have like that they have like
this like a periodic table of elements
right and they
have a wheel on it they like spin and
they got
a thorium and then they do some things
you know
like that no there are no women in this
okay fair fare
okay maybe i'll be the first woman you
know diversity cocktail waitress
oh yeah yeah no but i'll be the first
woman at the table like diversity come
on
okay so this is my one okay so i saw
this on tick tock of all places i love
tech talk
and um basically they were saying you
know that we're taught that the
earth is made up of several layers
you've got like the core and the mantra
the the mantle and the lava and all this
stuff
anyway so apparently this is actually
only a hypothesis
nobody has actually physically seen this
with their own eyes like this is just
the best hypothesis we have
right now and so we go with it and we
teach it but somebody basically came up
with this whole theory that there could
be
this entire civilization living within
earth like literally with and as as if
like earth is actually hollow
yeah um and i loved that and apparently
there was enough research to support it
but as if i've seen the research i
haven't um
but loved it no i i think that's a great
a great conspiracy another thing that i
only recently
was thinking about and um what's the
guy's name eric weinstein
he actually needed it and it was just by
coincidence i had been listening
to gosh what's the name of the book it
is called uh cosmic queries
by um what's the dude's name tyson
neil tyson degrassi and um
from listening to that book i was
sitting at the ocean and i was like you
know what
it's so egocentric to think and i think
it's egotistical or egocentric
right so egotistical to think that
aliens would be just interested
in humans right follow me here
giant ocean teeming with life
all of that life can communicate with
each other and has giant ecosystems
right we're a small
component of all the things on earth so
if another
alien like civilization zoomed
to earth why wouldn't they be interested
in like ants
like ants lift 15 times their body
weight and create
sophisticated civilizations or bees
why wouldn't they spend their time with
bees why does it always have to be like
probing a human in the rectum
lovely thank you for the picture really
appreciate that um
but like forget forget like what could
be on planet earth i definitely think
that there is stuff out there so in some
ways it is sort of
egotistical to think that they would
even be interested in us anyway
um but basically when i called you a
giga chad in
the title next to that i don't know if
you've seen but i also said
is bitcoin going to the moon is the
super cycle still happening now you
have a prediction for this year yeah
yeah yeah you're you're all for the
super cycle aren't you
well i don't know if it's super cycle
but i do think we're
a worse solid six figures by the end of
this year
solid six figures yeah i mean right now
whoops
bitcoin is thir you can't see it
thirty-four no i can't see it oh no yeah
right uh yeah yeah like we're
we're six figures by the end of this
year without a doubt
in my opinion like i i think and it
could be
like north of two hundred thousand
by the way yeah this year okay so can
you talk me
okay so can you talk me through um how
we're getting there because
i definitely i'm definitely not against
it i feel like we've had our nice fair
share of fud
we've managed to survive it china have
been we've managed to
you know survive that so so how do we
get to 200k by let's say december
or november that's my what max kaiser
says doesn't he yeah it's like
uh if you've ever read sun tzu and sun
tzu speaks about
um momentum and
how you generate force right and it's
like
drawing a bow back and the harder you
pull it back
the more force and momentum you actually
release
once you do that and i feel that
we're getting to kind of an apex
position with bitcoin you have energy
fund
you have institutional interest you have
all of the banks aping into positions
you have the first country uh calling
bitcoin legal tender you're going to
have a number of countries
follow suit those countries then that
are
um that have made bitcoin legal tender
are doing
interesting things doing countries one
country el salvador
air dropping 150 million dollars of
bitcoin
on its citizens thirty dollars per
citizen it does something very
interesting one it clarifies the fact
that you can buy fractions of bitcoin
too people in a digital environment
three they've made it uh they've made it
legal
to settle debts and i think you're going
to see a number of central american and
south american countries and i know for
you
u.s listeners you don't understand
geography
uh central america is not like the
middle of the united states there's a
whole
segment of the world that has other
countries and then
south america is not miami it's actually
a whole another continent it's really
cool and there are countries there too
and these countries do other things
other than what americans
do so anyway all of that momentum you
know that
bow being pulled back right the crack
two it's gonna be released
that's going to send bitcoin uh up
up and away and um regulation is going
to be favorable
taxation's going to be favorable the uk
is bad like they have a lot of bad
things going on their teeth are bad
the weather's bad it's pissing me great
you're i don't even know if you really
are uh
english because i don't you got good
teeth but
a lot of the teeth are not good they got
bad teeth i don't know what happens
there it's that crappy food you guys
eat or something to be honest like
that's an actual difference though
between brits and americans like i will
take that like when i went to america
last time i was in america i was like 18
or 19. um everybody had
perfect teeth unbelievable um but wait
let's go back let's go back to el
salvador because
oh my god it's so unbelievable um
i want to go and i think it will do so
much for the country everybody's like oh
it's so dangerous you don't actually
want to go
and perhaps maybe i won't go on my own
or maybe i'll go with
a group of people or whatever um but i
think you're a mccormick
he does chores i know i've seen
i've seen it's brilliant um but no i
think it's amazing you know mexico doing
the set uh hopefully we'll do something
similar
um i mean i do think that it will
be not just from like a financial and
economic standpoint but i think from
like a tourist standpoint it will be so
good for the country especially in
cleaning it up right yeah
when you were just saying like hey i'd
like to maybe go to
salvador someone should immediately
create either a surf
camp or a bitcoin kind of like report
right bang and just start this bitcoin
uh tourism going because there's so many
wonderful things like i would love
to go to el salvador and check out the
volcanoes and see what yeah
they're mining or you know like it could
be an amazing thing can you do it
right you can do it your time right
right you're a businessman you're always
like you're always innovating
the president doesn't follow me he
follows peter mccormick
we need to sort that out through you me
and peter need to get on a call that's
what needs to happen and then we'll
bring the president in
i can't even i can't even get verified
on twitter these guys
they hate me why can't you get verified
on twitter you're always on fox and
things like that no i don't know
i don't know i won't accept it though at
this point
i officially renounce any attempt to
verify me on twitter
yeah you don't want it not anymore fair
enough
i don't think i really wanted it in the
first place but now i definitely don't
want it you know what it is
it's dumb he's showing the piece of
paper again no i love it
um wait just like just lastly because i
i don't like like keep you too long so i
know you haven't eaten and you're
you're you're low on um your blood
levels are low bless you but basically
um today i saw that um a professor
and a finance professor at nyu said that
bitcoin
crap school overpriced muriel rabini
how many years does it take to get a
four-year degree at nyu
that's what i want to know how many
years to get a four-year degree
at nyu nuriel roubini go ahead leia
what what do you mean
are you saying how like university can
easily be done in like one year is that
what you're saying are you saying people
prolong it like
if this is an american thing i'm not
dying to totally
and there's no video to this
to this interview is that what this is a
audio only video uh interview it's big
okay so me using pictures isn't totally
insane
no no no it's not totally insane
yeah yeah like i do have a nice amount
of people that follow the google and
apple podcast version
um so that's cool um wait so before you
run because you've been
such a gentleman coming on my show last
minute um what are you working on at the
moment and what are you doing let's get
some self promo just
plug jason williams i am in an intense
bidding auction uh on christie's right
now for those of you who don't know that
as an elegant sophisticated british
american i'm a lover of fine art
and wine and all kinds of sophisticated
things
when you think of sophistication you
should think about the going parabolic
guy
i know i wear a baseball cap and
t-shirts almost all the time
but i'm highly sophisticated and so i'm
trying to buy
this ferocious art um you know this is
pride
month here in the united states i think
and
and fuocious is amazing and so um
i've got uh i got a 350 000
bid on one piece and a 220 000 bid on
another piece
i'm trying to yolo live life
there's one right behind me if uh right
there is a ferocious
original and uh and that's a cantona
jersey the king manchester united
eric the king cantona and that's what
i'm working on right now
the the auction's over in one hour and
31 minutes i'm watching it very closely
the bid is with me the bid is with me
i love that so you're just sitting on
christy's buying stuff
bidding and trading on nfts right i'm
bidding and then trolling the people who
i'm competing
against nice i like it it's a good day
it's a good day yeah and what are you
doing the rest of the day
after this i have uh i'm working on this
medical thing
building a bunch of primary care clinics
here in the united states
um that i'll work on
this afternoon uh some strategy meetings
and then the gym
uh yeah that's it i'm trying to build
these legs
some people called me out they said hey
man you got a lot of arms
but your legs look a little weak so you
know i'm gonna take that
so i've been in the gym for the last six
months crushing legs
three times a week leia when you see me
you're gonna go
what are you gonna say what do you think
you're watching
i'm gonna give you a hug to be honest
you're gonna give me a hug and i'm gonna
say look at this guy's legs i hadn't
seen the legs like this
two grand can we see can you show us can
you stand back and show us the legs
no i'm going to do a big reveal in el
salvador
i've got very sport about very short
shorts on
and i'm going to be walking with the
president up the mountain and people are
going to be like
look at that guy's legs incredible legs
this is the next thing you need to be
when you when you do this
you know tourism industry in el salvador
usually showing people volcanoes
with muscly legs and just walking around
just being like
this is all that's me my thing's gone
off and you need to just be showing
people
the muscley legs the volcanoes this is
what bitcoin is about just sell it you
know
it's gonna be like just let me get paint
the visual picture
my legs ronaldo a volcano
bitcoin mining it's it's going to be a
beautiful beautiful thing the world will
be a better place
climate change no one will even think
about it anymore they'll be like look at
those calves
i love it i love it no the energy is
great you haven't eaten
um no honestly jason i'm a huge fan um
so i want to thank you so much for
coming on my show
and i want to thank everyone for
listening um yeah i honestly think
you're brilliant um
so thanks so much and enjoy working
those legs at the gym
i'm on it thanks good to see you bye